[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOMINIC PREUSS: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to Google
Cloud Next 2017.
My name is Dominic
Preuss and I'm here
with Robert Kubis from our
developer advocate team.
And we're going to
spend some time talking
about Cloud Spanner.
So what are the goals
of this session?
First of all, we
want to take you
through a brief history of
Spanner and why Spanner exists.
Then we're going to
give you an explanation
of what Spanner is today
and what is available to you
in the public beta.
And then any good
session has a demo
and Robert will be taking
you through a demo.
The goal is to talk for about
30 minutes, do a 10 minute demo,
and then hopefully have
20 minutes for people
to ask questions at the end.
So hold your
questions at the end
and then please
come up to the mic
and ask a question
so we can make sure
that we get your question
on the recording.
So why does Spanner exist?
Let's go back to 2005.
Every dollar that Google
generated from its advertising
system AdWords was on the back
of a manually sharded MySQL
database.
That database was sharded
according to customer IDs
and occasionally we'd have
to reshard the database.
We did a reshard
and that reshard
actually took multiple
years to complete.
It was at that point we
decided that there's probably
a better way.
So we started
development of Spanner.
So as we were looking at the
requirements for the AdWords
system what were the
things that Google needed?
Google needed a horizontally
scalable database.
We had lots of customers.
We were growing quickly.
We had gone from a
$10 million business
to over a billion
dollar a year business
and we needed to
support that scale.
So we needed the
horizontal scalability.
The second thing is we were
dealing with people's money.
We had budgets.
We had customers.
We had partners.
We had agencies.
We had to have
asset transactions
with global consistency.
We couldn't accept
eventual consistency
or any loss of data.
So we had to make sure that
it was always consistent
and we always had
asset transactions.
The third thing was every minute
that the AdWord system was down
for maintenance was millions of
dollars of revenue for Google.
And so we had to have a
system that made sure that we
didn't have any downtime.
So these are the requirements.
And if you look at
this today, prior
to Cloud Spanner
entering the market
there was no good solution that
met all these requirements.
That brings us to Cloud Spanner.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We demand a lot
of our databases.
And our databases
demand a lot of us.
They're fragile, expensive,
and tough to maintain.
When things break it can be hard
to put the pieces back together
at the speed of your business.
And you often lose
data in the process.
We've all come to expect the
distributed databases can't
be globally consistent
and scalable.
But what if you didn't
have to make trade-offs?
What if you could have a
fully managed database service
that's consistent,
scales horizontally,
across data centers,
and speaks SQL?
This is Cloud Spanner, a mission
critical relational database
service built from the
ground up and battle
tested at Google for
strong consistency
and high availability
at global scale.
At Google we use
Spanner for services
that billions of people
access every day.
It's the only Cloud
service designed
to be a massively
distributed relational
database with transactions
and SQL semantics.
And we're talking massive.
Spanner can scale up to millions
of machines across hundreds
of data centers and trillions
of database rows stretching
across the globe while
behaving with like it's
all in one place,
where you want it.
We built Cloud Spanner to
be fully managed and secure.
Automatic sharding and
synchronous replication
with low latency and schema
updates without downtime
means your data is highly
available and reliable.
Instead of endless provisioning
and worrying about maintenance
you can focus on
growing your business.
No matter your
needs, you don't have
to hit a wall with
your database service.
Get started with Cloud Spanner.
And build what's next.
[END PLAYBACK]
DOMINIC PREUSS: Great so that
is our quick introduction
into what is Cloud Spanner.
So Cloud Spanner is Google's
mission critical scalable
relational database service.
So almost 10 years after
the internal Spanner project
went into productions
at Google, we've
been able to bring that
same level of performance
and consistency and scalability
to our Google Cloud platform
customers.
So what does that really mean.
So first of all Cloud Spanner
is a fully managed database
service.
So what that means is you don't
have to worry about upgrades.
You don't have to worry
about security patches.
You don't have to worry about
adding storage to your storage
array for the next set of
data that's going to come
in your database system.
All of that is handled for
you by our site Reliability
Engineering team who's making
sure 24/7 that that service is
up and running and that
we're meeting your needs.
Now we get fairly
pedantic inside of Google
around consistency.
And so when we say
asset transactions
and we mean global
consistency we
mean externalize
external serializability.
So it's the highest
standard of consistency.
There's a lot of back
and forth in the industry
about what is
eventual consistency,
or what is global consistency.
We take a very high bar on this.
And Spanner meets that need.
So this means that you
have asset transactions
across many rows.
You have relational semantics.
So if you're coming off of
a manually sharded MySQL
database or a postgres cluster
or some other SQL solution
everything looks familiar.
So your schemas are defined
in DDL so standard SQL
with SQL data types.
You are able to do queries based
on your joins and everything
you're used to having in SQL.
In fact, Cloud Spanner
uses the same SQL dialect
as what we've rolled
out in BigQuery, which
is based on Anti-SQL
2011 with some extensions
for the additional features
that Google offers.
So with the standard
SQL and it's
the same SQL that you get
across the Google Cloud
platform on our data
warehousing product BigQuery.
It's automatic
synchronous replication.
So today in the beta, we've
rolled out regional versions
of Cloud Spanner.
So what that means is we
have multiple replicas
across multiple zones
inside of a single region.
And this gives you four
nines of availability.
It also means that
when you write data
into Spanner in
the Cloud Spanner,
you know that it
has been written.
If we've given you
an acknowledgment
that that transaction
has committed,
then you know that
data is there in any
reads that you do
after that time
stamp will include that data.
We give these guarantees
so that you always
know that you're getting
the most consistent view
of your data at all times, or
a consistent view of your data
at all times.
Later in the year we'll be
rolling out multi-regional.
So multi-regional means that you
can actually span your database
across multiple Google
Cloud Platform regions
to achieve an even higher
level of availability.
So multi-regional
Cloud Spanner instances
will offer five nines
of availability.
So what that means is you're
talking about 20 seconds
a month, I'm sorry two
seconds a month of downtime
with five nines.
And this has been battle tested.
And the reason that
I can get up on stage
and make these
types of claims is
because we know that we've
done this internally.
So we've been doing
this at Google
for almost 10 years with
the internal Spanner system.
And so we know that when
we make these guarantees
of availability and
consistency and durability,
we can stand behind
them, because we
have almost 10 years of
battle tested experience
running it internally.
Google Cloud Spanner
has been used internally
for many of our mission
critical applications.
So we've talked about Google
AdWords, the Google Play Store,
and in fact Google
Cloud Platform
itself is built on
top of Cloud Spanner.
So the control plane that
manages all of the VMs
and all of the services
across Google Cloud platform
is actually based on Spanner.
So you can have confidence
that when you put your data
and build your application
on the top of Cloud Spanner
you're getting the best of
what Google has to offer.
So Dominic, you just
said a bunch of words.
What does that mean?
How does that compare
to other solutions?
So if you compare it to a
traditional relational database
with traditional RDBMS,
we have strong schemas.
We have SQL schemas
and querying.
We have strong consistency.
We have high availability.
Quite often I get asked,
how does Cloud Spanner
compare to the RDBMS that
I'm using either on premise
or in another public cloud?
And invariably they're trying
to compare a single node
solution to Spanner, which
is a distributed system.
So when you have a single node
master slave configuration,
you're dependent
on the master node.
That means that you can
only do as many rights
as you can put through
the master node.
And if the master node needs
to be updated, either get
a new version of software,
get a security patch,
need to do any maintenance, you
either have to take the master
node down and take
down the whole system,
or failover your master
node to your slaves
you can do maintenance
on the master.
What this means is
that your application
will incur downtime.
Now that downtime
might be scheduled.
But it's still downtime.
For Google it doesn't matter.
We're selling ads
around the world.
We can't schedule downtime.
We're making money and
we have a system that
is reliant on the system 24/7.
So we can't have
downtime, either scheduled
or unscheduled.
So Cloud Spanner, because
of its distributed nature,
means that we can do
updates, security updates,
any maintenance that we
need to do in the system
by moving your data around
on the multiple nodes.
And you don't see any downtime.
In fact you see nothing
on the performance side
of what you experience.
You'll see consistent
experience even
when we're doing things like
upgrades and security patches.
So in that sense, it's
horizontally scalable.
So the way that you
achieve additional scale
is you add nodes, which
is what you would normally
see a NoSQL database, which
we'll talk about in a second.
So instead of relying on
vertical scalability, which
means that if I need more
throughput through my master
slave, I just put
it on a bigger box.
I give it more RAM.
I give it more memory.
And so that's the
vertical scaling strategy.
And so with Spanner, we give
you horizontal scalability.
So you don't worry about I'm
on the biggest VM I really
hope this provider makes a
bigger VM because when I'm
going to run out of size soon.
Right, you know
that we can always
add additional capacity so that
you can grow your application.
Also replication, so traditional
RDBMSs, one of the ways
that you can scale
out horizontally
is you can shard your
read and write workloads.
So you can add additional
read replicas to your system.
And then you can do your reads
off of those read replicas.
Therefore giving additional
capacity to your master node.
Now the problem there
is that those reads
of the read replicas are stale.
There is a replication
lag for the data that's
making that read replica.
And so it's up to you
and your application
to know that you may or
may not have the most
consistent version of the data.
If you need a
consistent read you
have to go back to the master
node and therefore using up
some those resources and take
away some of your scalability.
So that's how it relates
to a traditional RDBMS.
How does it relate to NoSQL?
So the pattern that we
would see over and over
and over again with
our customers is,
both our enterprise
and our start-ups
and smaller companies,
is that they
would build an application
using a traditional RDBMS.
It might be MySQL,
might be postgres,
might be name your
commercial database.
And then what happens
is they just grew.
And we all know that data
is growing exponentially.
It is growing faster--
at a faster rate than its
ever grown in our history.
And so the requirements that
we have in our databases
continues to grow.
And so often what happens
is a company or project
has this relational database
that backs their application.
And they hit the upper bound
of what they can do for scale.
So there are only
immutable requirement
is horizontal scalability.
So they then go and choose
a NoSQL solution, Cassandra,
Maunganui, whatever
it happens to be.
And they basically
trade global consistency
for horizontal scalability.
Because that is their
immutable requirement.
And then they write a
bunch of application logic.
Or use other tools
to try to get around
the transactional semantics
of having consistency only
at a shard level, or not
across the entire database.
So what Spanner
allows you to do is
to not have to make this trade.
Now if you've
outgrown your RDBMS
Cloud Spanner is not
a drop in replacement.
It's not a SQL
compatible database.
It's not a postgres
So there is going to be
work for you required
to migrate your traditional
RDBMS application on the Cloud
Spanner.
But you get to know that
when you make that transition
you don't have to
make a trade off
between horizontal scalability
and global consistency.
I'm often asked,
what was the hardest
thing about taking the
internal Spanner application
and exposing it to our Google
Cloud Platform customers.
And the answer is
making it open.
So Google is committed
to being the open Cloud.
And so we've done
everything we can
to adopt open standards and
existing protocols and APIs
that exist in the outside world.
We aren't trying
to move everyone
on to Google
proprietary technology.
We're trying to move and
solve customers' needs
where they are, by
supporting those standards.
And so Cloud Spanners
spent a tremendous amount
of time trying to make
sure that this was true.
So we started with standard SQL.
We've had a number of
different SQL dialects
across the Google
Cloud Platform.
And so we decided
that we needed to come
to a standard SQL dialect
across all Google products.
So we took Ansi-SQL 2011 as a
spec and then extended that.
And so what this means is
when you look at SQL Spanner,
SQL in Spanner you
see normal SQL data
types and the types
of queries and joins
and things that
you would expect.
So we make it as easy as
possible for customers
by reducing the friction
in the impedance mismatch
between their existing solution.
The second thing is
we spent a lot of time
on enterprise requirements.
Cloud Spanner actually launched
with the best integration
across all of our various
cross-platform initiatives
for identity and access
management encryption and auto
logging.
It came out of the gate in
beta with all of the features
that traditional enterprise
that has high security needs
would need to be able
to adopt this product.
And so we spent a lot of
time investing in that,
and making sure that the
product had those features
from the very beginning.
We also spent a lot of
time in client libraries.
So we'd like to talk about
being a very developer
friendly platform.
And being developer
friendly means two things.
I mean you've got
great documents
and great documentation.
And you have really
strong client libraries.
So we spent a ton of time
working with our early access
customers.
Cloud Spanner was in early
access for over 12 months.
And what we were
doing in that time
was onboarding customers,
showing the documents,
finding the holes in the
places that we forgot
to document things,
adding those documents
and really doing
lots of iterations
on the documentation, so that
when we launched we actually
had all of that ready
for our developers.
The second thing that
was really important
was our client libraries.
So we spent a ton of time
on our Java, Python, Go
and node.js client
libraries to make sure
that they were fully baked.
They were optimized
for performance.
We obscured any of
the common gotchas
that you would have if you were
trying to use the API directly
in an idiomatic way
for the language.
So we spent a ton of time
working with the various teams
to make sure that we had a
first class developer client
library in these languages.
The last thing is JDBC.
In case you haven't
heard this yet,
the partner ecosystem is
incredibly important to Google.
And so one of the
things that we did
to make it as easy as possible
for both customers to adopt
and partners, is that we
launched with a JDBC driver.
The JDBC driver is read-only.
And what that means is
that we can hand that
to a number of our partners
or your internal customers.
And they have a fully
understood client library
that they can often plug-in
with very little work
to their frameworks.
And this allowed us
to launch integrations
with a number of partners early
because we were able to deliver
them a JDBC driver.
And that was able to
decrease the time necessary
for them to implement
access in the Cloud Spanner.
So what types of workloads are
appropriate for Cloud Spanner?
So as we were going through
the early access program
we saw a number
of patterns emerge
from the types of use cases that
people found for Cloud Spanner.
So the first one
was transactional.
If you have an
application that requires
transactional consistency
or complex transactions,
then that is an ideal
use case for Spanner.
So if you're dealing with
things like inventory management
where you can't sell more
products than you have,
or if you are trying to
manage financial transactions
you have to make sure that you
always have the right amounts.
And you have to have really
strong transactional semantics
to be able to support that.
So what we saw is a
number of the companies
that we've worked with had
a manually sharded system,
or had built a
transactional system
on top of their manually
sharded or eventually consistent
Datastore to make sure
that they were guaranteeing
transactional consistency.
So what Spanner
allows you to do is
to push all of the
transactional code
and all of the responsibilities
for maintaining
transactional consistency
into the database.
So what this means
is that you have
much simpler architectures,
much higher velocity
for your developers, less code
that can go wrong and introduce
bugs, because you can
rely on the database
itself for maintaining
and providing
all of your transactional
consistency.
The second one was scaleout.
And people often assume that
unless they have tons of data
they can't use Spanner.
And the answer is if you have
mission critical system that
requires high
availability then Spanner
can be a great fit for you.
If you have 10 gigabytes of
data or you have a pentabyte
of data, it doesn't matter.
You have a mission
critical application.
And so Cloud Spanner gives
you a Cloud native mission
critical database that
also provides scale.
So if you have hit the upper
bounds of what you can do
and we continue to see other
Cloud providers and database
providers rolling out kind
of incremental changes
in the amount of data
that they can store.
What Spanner does is
allows you to have
a non-incremental change.
We go from being able to
store specific single digit
terabytes of data into
as much data as you have.
So if you happen to have
a very large customer set
or large number of
transactions or a lot of data
that you have to have
transactional consistency,
then Spanner allows you to
meet that need without having
to take any trade-offs.
Another common use case
is Global Data Plane.
And this is very common
inside of Google and actually
the Google Cloud
Platform use case.
So if you have--
let's say that you
have user bases that
are around the world.
You have a set of
users in North America,
a set of users in Europe,
and a set of users in Asia.
And you want to keep all
of the user data close
to the customers
then you can do that.
You can have a regional
instance or an RDBMS in the US,
one in Europe and one in Asia.
But what you need
to know is have
a single global
system that tells you
where that data lives.
So for this user, user
ABC, I know that data
that user is homed in Europe.
So I'm going to go to
the European instance
to go ahead and get that data.
And so these Global
Control Plane
where it might be a very
small amount of data.
But you have to be able to
query it from everywhere,
have low latency and
know that you have
a consistent view the data is
a very common use case we saw
both inside of Google
and we're starting
to see more commonly
in the outside world.
The last one is
database consolidation.
So everyone knows
the story, right
you keep your user data
in MySQL or postgres.
You keep all your event and
logs data in a Cassandra cluster
or in BigQuery.
And then you ETL
the data around.
Right every night you copy
a copy of your user table
into BigQuery so you
can do joins against it.
What we're seeing
with Cloud Spanner
is it allows you to
consolidate your databases
into a single source of truth.
So you could take
your user data which
that might be in
postgres or MySQL,
and you can merge it
with all the events data
that you have in Cassandra
or Maunganui or BigQuery.
And you can combine them
into a single database.
You no longer have
to ETL data around.
You don't have to worry
about staleness of data.
You can do joins
across all the data
and you know that you have
a single consistent source
of truth for all of that data.
Again it is a tremendous
gain in productivity
for your development
teams if they
don't have to worry about
multiple data stores.
If you can put all
of your data in one
place, and Cloud Spanner
makes sense for that.
It removes tremendous
complexity from your stack.
So that removes bugs.
It makes it easier to maintain
code, increases developer
velocity.
And this is again
something we've
seen a lot inside of Google.
And we're starting to see
with our Google Cloud platform
customers.
So how does Spanner do this?
I say that it's
horizontally scalable.
So what does that mean?
So for Cloud Spanner you start
with a Cloud Spanner instance.
And Robert is going to demo how
to actually create one of these
and you can see how easy it is.
But you create a Cloud
Spanner, for instance,
and when you create
that instance
you basically tell us what you
want your replication topology
to look like.
So if you're using a
regional Spanner instance,
we have multiple replicas
in multiple zones
inside of a single region.
And then each of
those replicas has
its own set of compute
resources and storage.
And then you put your database
inside of that instance.
So an instance can
have 100 databases.
And then each database
can have 2,000 tables.
And each of those tables can
have as many rows as you want.
And so what this means is
that your data is actually
replicated across
each of the replicas.
And we've got full copies of
all the data in all the places.
And so there is
multiple replicas
running at any given time.
So what happens is if
somebody comes in and wants
to make an update.
So let's say that you want to
update a row in a database.
Or let's say you
want update 100 rows.
That update comes
into the system
and goes into one
of the replicas.
This is where Spanner
magic starts to happen.
That update comes
into the system.
We know that each of the
different replicas has parts.
They have all the data.
But we know that certain
parts of the data
are owned by different nodes.
So when that update
comes in, we come in
and we notify the
appropriate nodes.
And then that data
gets replicated
across all of the replicas.
We use a custom
Paxos algorithm that
allows us to do consensus
based writes on the system.
And this is what allows us to
have our global consistency.
So we have a custom
Paxos algorithm.
And we have two-phase
commits which
allows us to have global
consistency across the database
at all times.
We try to do everything
without the two-phase commit.
But if you actually
are joining it,
you're trying to update
data across multiple nodes
that we fall back
to two-phased commit
to make sure that we don't lose
consistency of the database.
This is all well and good
and Spanner sounds magic.
But there has to be
some differences.
There can't just be a
drop in replacement.
And the answer is you're right.
So to get the advantages
of a distributed system
we impose certain
design constraints
or we impose certain concepts.
So the first one is the way
that we leave out the data.
So in a regular
relational database
if you had two sets of
data that were related,
you would have two tables
and you may or may not
have a foreign key constraint.
Which would allow if
you delete one row
and it deletes all
of the children rows.
And so this is the way
you would lay it out
in a normal relational database.
Postgres SQL does
support child tables,
which implement some of this
but for different reasons.
So what we've done in
Spanner to make it performant
and to help customers
tell us what data should
be grouped together we have the
concept of interleaved tables.
So what this means
is that when you
have tables that are
dependent on each other,
you literally interleave them
together into the same table.
So you can see our top level
row is the Beatles, where
the artist's ID is number 1.
And then we have albums
that are under it
that are from the artist
and they have IDs 1 and 2.
So we have a primary key
for The Beatles, which is 1,
and then 1 and 2, which are
the primary keys for the child
table.
What this tells us is that
all of the information that
is under Beatles is related.
And so what that allows
us to do is to group
all of the data together
on a single node.
So if you commonly are
doing queries where you say,
show me all of the
songs for the Beatles.
Or show me all the
albums for the Beatles.
And you know that
your queries are
going to be within
a subset of the data
by using interleaved
tables you can tell us
the logical grouping
of your data.
And this allows
us to do a better
job of splitting the data
across multiple nodes, which
allows us to respond to queries
more quickly because we don't
have to rely on
two-phase commit.
We can serve all the data off
of that one section of the data
in a very quick way.
So what does this look like
from a schema point of view?
So when you defined
your schema, as we
talked about we used
DDLs standard SQL create
table singer's, singer ID,
is INT64 not null singer
name as a string max length.
And primary key is singer ID.
So we need this primary key to
know how to split your data up
and shard your
data across nodes.
So that if albums is a
subset of all the state
and is dependent on the
parent table, then we can say
create table albums,
singer ID INT64.
So child tables have to
have all of the primary keys
of its parent.
So it has to have singer ID.
And then we've added album
ID as a second primary key.
And we also have an album
name which is string.
And then when we
define the table
we say interleave in singers.
And so this is the concept
of foreign key constraints
that Spanner supports.
It's not arbitrary
foreign key constraints
because that doesn't work
on a distributed system.
By telling us how to group
all the data together then
you can start to do things
like cascade on delete
and some of the other
benefits that you get
from a foreign key constraint.
But we only do this at a
interleave table basis.
The other thing that's great,
that I love telling customers
about, is schema migrations.
So the other thing that
this allows us to do
is no downtime
schema migrations.
So you can actually
alter your table
and add a column,
in this case age.
We can apply that
to the database.
And that updates the schema on
the fly so no downtime online.
And you know that once
that transaction--
schema update is out of the
transaction, once that commits,
you know that all subsequent
reads after that transaction
have the new data.
Again getting back
to the problem
we talked about with
AdWords, we couldn't
handle either
locking the database
or shutting down the database
to do schema migrations.
We needed to be able to do
schema migrations on the fly.
So alterations to the
schema are online.
So what does this
look like in code?
So in any of these
sessions we try to give you
actionable information.
I'm a Python guy
so I've gone ahead
and pulled the Python code.
So if you use our Google
Cloud client libraries.
So we have-- we've rolled
open source client libraries
in all the primary languages.
So if I install the Python
Google Cloud library into PIP,
so PIP install Google-Cloud.
I can then import Spanner
from Google Cloud.
I instantiate a client.
So that client allows me
to talk to the service.
I then say I need my instance so
please give me my instance ID.
And then from the instance,
I can grab my database.
So I say what does
my database ID?
And then I ask my
instance for the database.
I now have a handle
to my database
where I can start
to send queries.
So I could do results sets
by saying database.executeSQL
and pass it SQL queries.
And so these 10
lines of code are
all that is necessary
to be able to be
up and running with your
Cloud Spanner instance.
We really tried to make
it as easy as possible.
There's lots of
intermediate steps
that are happening
here that we've
been able to obscure by
having really strong client
libraries that do a lot
of the heavy lifting
underneath the hood for you,
things like connection pooling
and things that could be gotchas
if you aren't familiar with how
to use the service.
So right before we
get into the demo,
how does this fit into
the broader schema?
So Cloud Spanner
sounds fantastic.
Is it the solution
for everything?
The answer is no.
Cloud Spanner is one of
a portfolio of solutions
that allow you to build
your application on top
of Google Cloud platform.
So starting with
Cloud SQL, So if you
have a framework whether it be
Django or WordPress or Drupal
that requires
MySQL, then you can
use Cloud SQL to manage
that MySQL instance for you.
So it's a traditional
RDBMS that's
being managed for you by Google.
If you have a document
database workload commonly
in mobile and web,
then Cloud Datastore
provides you that
data in a database.
Fully scalable, it's
shared resources,
you can literally
start from zero dollars
a month all the way
up to SnapScale,
who just went public.
So you can scale all the
way up on Cloud Datastore
if your data is non-relational
and fits into a document
database workload.
Cloud Bigtable is our
analytics database.
So this allows you to do low
latency single millisecond
reads and writes and really fast
table scans for your OIT time
series Ad Tech data
MarTech data it's
a fantastic solution for that.
And then BigQuery is
our data warehouse
that allows you to write
all your data in, mostly
append, some mutation so you can
update and clean up your data.
But it's really
our data warehouse.
So what Cloud Spanner
does in the portfolio is
gives you a place that if you've
gone to MySQL in Cloud SQL
and you're using that
as your solution.
If you need to be
able to scale past it
you know that Google
provides you an option.
So it really gives you
a future proof path
to be able to move
from your existing
application on either
MySQL or postgres
or whatever you happen
to be using and continue
to grow out as a scaleout
relational database.
And with that I'm going
to bring up Robert to get
started on the demo.
One other thing,
one of the questions
that I just went through,
I use a lot of words.
Flowcharts are usually helpful.
So what we did here
is we put together
a decision tree that
allows you to decide
which database service you
would use for which offering.
So first of all, is your data
structured or unstructured?
If your data is
unstructured you're
going to put in a
Google Cloud Storage.
That way you can use
it in access it there.
If you need mobile SDKs
then Firebase Storage
will provide you a mobile SDK
on the Google Cloud Storage.
If your data is structured
then the question
is your data analytics.
Do you have an
analytics workload?
In which case you'll come
over to the analytics branch.
If you need low latency
and lots of mutations
use Cloud Bigtable, if you
don't use cloud BigQuery.
Coming back down the middle
if your data is relational
and the answer is no, then
you have Cloud Datastore.
And if you have
mobile applications
you have Firebase
real time database
that provides you
mobile SDKs for iOS Java
and the mobile applications.
If your data is relational
then the question
is the new horizontal
scalability?
If you don't need
horizontal scalability then
Cloud SQL is a great
solution for you
and is going to be
your easiest path
to building an application.
If you're doing
horizontal scalability
Cloud Spanner is there
to meet your needs.
So this is a quick way for
you to kind of navigate
which the various database
technologies will serve
the need for your application.
And lastly before we get to
the demo, as I said before,
partner integration is
very important to us.
It's why we spend a lot of
time on the JDBC driver.
So we're very excited to have
xplenty, Zoomdata, looker
and MicroStrategy and iCharts.
They all are in the
process of launching
or have already launched
support for Cloud Spanner.
So some of your favorite BI
tools are already integrated.
And we're working
with informatica,
alooma, Tableau,
they've started work
and they'll be rolling out their
solutions later in the year.
So again, if you are already
using Tableau or looker or one
of these solutions
in your stack we're
going to make sure
that we're integrated
from the very beginning to
make it as easy as possible
to migrate data in and
out of Cloud Spanner.
So with that I
give it to Robert.
ROBERT KUBIS: All right,
thank you Dominic.
Hello everyone, so
Dominic presented to you
a lot of features and arguments
of why to use Spanner.
So I want to show you how you
can get started today with it.
So your first stop should
be Cloud.Google.com/Spanner,
where find a wealth of
information about our Spanner
product.
You find white papers,
best practices,
you find Eric Brewer's recap
on the cap theory and Spanner.
So there you also find
your developer docs.
And I want to stop here and asks
the question, how many of you
are developers here in the room?
Awesome, so you're the
right audience for me.
So we, as Dominic
mentioned, we have
a couple of client libraries--
Go, Java, Node.js, and Python.
I'm going to concentrate
on Go if I get to it today.
So to get started
within the instance
you go to the cloud console.
So console.cloud.google.com.
Make sure that
you are logged in.
And then you have
on the left side
a nice drawer here you
can type in Spanner.
And you find it.
And you can go there.
So to create an instance,
you click an instance.
You choose a name.
awesomespanner, for instance.
And then select
regional configuration.
Now you have the, as
Dominic mentioned,
the multi-regional is
coming up later this year.
Right now you can choose between
three regions Asia, Europe
and US.
I'm going to choose Europe.
I'm personally from
Europe, so I prefer Europe.
I want to have my
Spanner instance
to give me all the answers.
So I select 42 nodes.
And we create.
And as you can see, with
a snap of the finger
you have your instance
with 42 nodes.
So now we can get started
and create a database.
So here I choose OK.
I created demo database
and I create an schema.
So I select the
table you can all
do this also form the
command line with gcloud--
download to gcloud
SDK and then you
can do all this on the
command line as well.
So for instance,
we have the singer.
We had an ID.
And then we say a name,
which is a string here.
OK done.
And then you select
your primary key.
You add the table.
And now you have
your first table.
Now we can add another
table and that's
as we mentioned before, I
think we had albums here.
We can now interleave
this as well.
So I want to, for instance,
interleave or not.
So it can go through all
this and create this.
Let me choose this.
I want to interleave the
table with my single table.
I want to delete
on cascade delete.
So I get already the ID as my
primary key from the album.
And then for instance I say
it's like an album name here.
All right, and you get a string.
You're done.
You have to choose a
primary key as well.
And we add the table here.
Say album name.
OK.
Cool and we create.
So that's basically
done in background
as we mentioned before,
we have an online update.
So you can see
already it's done.
Cool now I want to switch
to a different instance
where I have some
preloaded data.
So in this preloaded data I
have a scenario where I have,
think of Ticketmaster
or something
where you can buy tickets.
And to explain that
to you a little bit.
I have a crappy schema here.
Sorry about my drawing skills.
So what I'm going to show
you here, I want to show you
some best practices, how we
came up with this schema,
and what you have
to pay attention
to if you want to
scale horizontally
with your database.
So here you have multi-event.
Think of a tour, for instance,
a Coldplay tour which
is in many, many countries.
So the ColdPlay tour
would be a multi-event.
Each of the concerts in
each country is an event.
Then you have different venues
which have different seating
configuration.
Think of like a
stadium which can have
sports events or a concert.
And then we have
a ticket category
which basically gives us
attaches a price to a ticket
for a certain event.
So with the cold Coldplay
concert in a stadium
we have a certain ticket
price for each seat.
And then you see on the right
upper corner an account.
So that would
basically somebody who
comes to our website
and signs up and wants
to buy a ticket that would
be representing that account.
So now if this table
pre-loaded here
and what you can also
see here in the console
is you have a multitude of
things that you can check into.
So we see already
here my database
is mere seven gigabytes.
Big.
I can go to the
monitor tab, see things
like how many nodes do I have?
How much CPU
utilization do I have?
And we recommend
not to go over 75%.
So if you see that you're
approaching this utilization
you can easily add nodes.
You see operations and
throughputs and things
like that.
So this little spike
that you see here
was me loading the database.
OK so I want to show
you an example query
that I have here, which
is based on the schema
that I just showed you.
So the capability that you have
as well here in the console
you can directly run your
queries out of the console.
So I going to run this query.
It should be rather quick.
What does this query do?
It basically gives you back
the events for the next week
where you still have a lot of
seats available for this event.
So you see here we
have a couple of events
with 10,000 available seats.
And then the seats
availability, basically,
how many tickets didn't we
that we have not sold so far.
So this is for instance
a query that you
could use to promote events
that are not going well in terms
of selling your tickets.
Now we see, if I go
to the explanation tab
you get a query explained.
And you can see what
is this query doing.
I see here a couple of
table scans that I'm doing,
disputed unions and
things like that.
And I looked at
this query before
and I saw OK this is
not performing optimal.
So what can I do if a query
is not performing optimal?
And as like with any like bigger
database, relational database,
that you have out there
you have the possibility
to give the
optimizer some hints.
And that's exactly what
I going to do here.
And so it was
mentioned by Dominic
that we have the Ansi 2011
scale standard with extensions.
And one of these
extensions is that I can
force an index for instance.
So I am an index to find
on my seating category,
and I say at and
then the prices,
and say force index
seating category by ID.
And I run this
whole query again.
And if you have paid attention
you saw this query run before
in 750 milliseconds.
So fingers crossed
this is better.
Now you see here I did an an
optimizer hint and now my query
runs three time faster and
scans and a lot less rows.
All right, so
another thing what we
have all of the Cloud
products they are integrated
with the products that we have.
So one of the products for
instance, for monitoring
is our Stackdriver solution.
So in Stackdriver
what you can do
is you can monitor, your
Cloud Spanner instance.
And I have here pre-created
dashboard and I want to add
some more--
some more things.
So right now I have nodes and
storage, which I'm monitoring.
If you want to add more
things you basically
can select from the charts.
You have here a resource
type Cloud Spanner.
And then you can select the
metric that you want to select.
So for instance, I want to
check this CPU utilization.
OK and then you
can select and say,
OK, I only want to have that
monitoring one of my databases.
And the nice thing of
this is you can also
set up alerts with this.
So if your Spanner instance
is approaching a certain grade
of utilization or
storage then you
can get alerts to your phone and
can easily increase node count.
So node count-- adding
or taking nodes away
if you want to save money.
Or you like utilization is
lower you can all the time
go to your instance added nodes.
And for instance go from 8 to 5.
And then say Save.
And then we will
reduce the nodes.
So it's a fully
managed solution.
Where it's very
easy to set it up,
get started, load data, scale
in and scale out as you wish.
So how are we doing on time?
So one more thing.
Dominic mentioned
he is a Python guy.
I'm a Go guy.
So I'm usually doing Go.
So how does it look in Go?
It's very easy as well.
So what you do is basically you
have the database pass where
you load or take the instance,
or the project, the instance
and the database that
you want to talk to,
you set up in a client.
We have that here.
And then you can basically
run your queries.
So what I'm doing here
is a very simple query.
I want to have all
the multi-events that
are happening for today.
And because I don't care if
I'm a little bit out of date
with this, I actually can define
time bounds for this query.
So I can actually say to
Spanner on say like hey,
I don't want to have a strong
consistent read in this case.
Because I don't think that
we update the multi-events
so often.
So I'm OK if I do have a
little bit of staleness.
And in this case,
what you see here,
I'm saying like I'm OK with
15 seconds of staleness.
And that allows
you for instance,
in the multi-regional
set up to read
from a local copy in
a different region,
even so if there's not
the primary copy of it.
All right so with that
I want to lead into Q&A.
And I want to ask Dominic
to come back on stage.
And we are here for you
to answer any questions.
DOMINIC PREUSS:
And so we're going
to do-- we've got about
15 minutes for Q&A. So
if you have questions
please come up to the mic.
Last thing is I want to put
a quick plug-in for some
of our other sessions.
So if you're
interested in Spanner
and databases in general, we
have the Spanner 201 session
tomorrow.
We have a great session
on optimizing Cloud SQL
performance.
A good class again on talking
about other storage solutions.
So I didn't spend time
on Google Cloud Storage
or some of the other ones.
And also Zero to
app, live coding
an app with Firebase
and GCP, which
is one of my favorite
sessions that I've seen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]